today's video has been made possible by
world of tanks if you enjoy online team
based shooters or you just like to see
my strategic genius when it comes to
driving tanks then stick around until
the end of the video
um
[Music]
oh
when we think of angels the images
conjured are often quite similar radiant
winged figures with many human traits
we see this imagery in modern depictions
as well as in classical art so one would
assume this is how they are described in
biblical and ancient texts but this is
far from the truth
angels take more of a spiritual form as
opposed to a physical one
there is no real description of what an
angel's true form is but there are some
descriptions of the bodies they assume
and be warned they are very strange so
let's take a look at some of the
different types of angels
in the 12th century scholars divided all
of the angels around god into categories
based on a hierarchical system in
christianity this is sometimes referred
to as the three spheres and the nine
orders of angels because it describes a
three-tier system with three types of
angels in each tier
near the bottom of this hierarchy are
the cherubim
the book of ezekiel describes them as
having four faces each one representing
something different
the lion represented wild animals
the ox domesticated the animals
the eagle birds
and the human represented humanity
the cherubim had long straight legs with
hooves and two pairs of wings you may
also see them with regular feet and four
pairs of wings
a much different appearance to the young
plump cherubs we would associate with
figures such as cupid that stem from
christian scholars such as thomas
aquinas who characterize them as having
a burning love for god
the hebrew bible mentions the word
cherubim almost 100 times but their
purpose is still fairly ambiguous
the general belief is that they exist to
guard the garden of eden especially the
tree of life
the cherubim having numerous faces has
this almost chimera feel but the human
face is more akin to a sphynx
either way there is something very
unsettling about their appearance
the seraphim are a type of angel that
appear in christianity judaism and islam
but their importance varies
in judaism they are middle of the road
but in christianity they assume the
highest rank possible just under god
the book of isaiah describes them as
having six wings
above it stood the seraphims each one
had six wings
with twain he covered his face
and with twain he covered his feet and
with twain he did fly
and one cried unto another and said
holy holy holy is the lord of hosts the
whole earth is full of his glory from
this passage we gather that two of these
six wings were used to cover their faces
two to cover their feet
and the last two were used to fly
the second passage describes them almost
as cheerleaders who fly around the
throne of god spreading his word
this description is not as detailed as
the cherubim so all we know for sure is
that the seraphim were made up of mostly
wings
the book of revelation only differs
slightly describing their six wings as
being full of eyes
in islam we see the term seraph which is
used to describe archangels who were
born from celestial fire
next we have the thrones or the ophenym
these are about as far from a
traditional looking angel as one can get
in christianity the opening were the
entities that acted as chariots or
transportation for the cherubim
they were giant interlocking wheels with
wings and eyes that would reside in the
part of the cosmos where material form
began to shape
like the seraphim they would also chant
god's glory whenever in his presence
the book of enoch describes them as the
many eyed ones and places them in the
same category of celestial being as the
cherubim and seraphim
their role here was much more than
transportation
the ophanim never sleep and forever
guard the throne of god when ezekiel has
his vision of the great chariot he
describes all three of these angels as
the guardians but given the strange
nature of what he's describing some
believe this was a hallucination others
take ezekiel's account as an encounter
with ufos
so no one really knows where they came
from and why they look so strange
the virtues are a group of angels who do
not possess a physical body but have
control over the elements they were
referred to as the shining ones because
they appear as sparks of light
the main role of the virtues was to
perform miracles for those who were
deemed as deserving
they would receive orders from the
angels above them and travel to earth to
perform these miracles
once on earth they would assume a human
form
there are several types of angels along
with the virtues whose primary form
resembles a source of light
angels are celestial beings
they are neither male nor female and
essentially they can take whatever form
they desire
is it a surprise that the angels who
spend all of their time in the cosmos
with god are the strangest and most
unorthodox looking
no not really
if you're talking about regions that are
supposed to be outside of our
comprehension then surely the beings
that inhabit them would also look out of
place
even if that means they resemble
something you'd expect to see in a
lovecraftian horror or perhaps the
writings of someone coming down of an
acid trip
it also makes sense for the archangels
and regular angels to appear in a more
human light as they have the most human
interaction
the further back you delve into various
religious texts the stranger angels
appear to be
as later books were added and revised
the more human-looking angels became the
norm and maybe this was done to make
things easier to understand
in reality we may never know
but it's still interesting to examine
as mentioned earlier today's video has
been sponsored by world of tanks a
free-to-play online multiplayer team
shooter where everyone has their own
tank there's no need to worry though you
don't need to be an expert in tank
warfare to enjoy the game take me for
example i know nothing about tanks but
the game is fast paced and simple enough
that everyone can enjoy themselves
you can place yourself strategically on
the battlefield and outsmart the enemy
team or like me you can just charge in
all guns blazing and most likely be the
first one to die every game when the
enemy team just turns around and blows
you to pieces
during my time playing i've tried a
range of different tanks and although it
is very fun playing as the light tanks
that can skirt around the edge of the
map undetected the firepower of a medium
tank like the t-34 is just unrivalled
there is a large array of historically
accurate tanks that you can choose from
and customize to your own taste
whether you're with friends or by
yourself world of tanks is full of fast
and highly explosive fun you can use the
link in the description to sign up and
play today
new players can also use the code tank
mania to receive 250 000 credits seven
days of premium access and three rental
tanks for free so if you're looking for
something to do in your spare time then
why not try world of tanks today
as always
i've been your host
mythology and fiction explained
[Music]
[Music]
you